Sonja Kraus ist einer der Gäste bei
klickum die so richtig Spaß am
Fragenlotto hat deswegen jetzt wieder
interessantes von ihr und wir kitzeln
z.B aus ihr heraus dass Lügen angreifbar
macht und die Wahrheit entwaffnend ist
warum das so ist das sieht jetzt im
Fragenlotto du hast ja noch nach bösen
Fragen gefragt a das sind die bösen die
sind da drin die sind rot dann neh die
sind nicht rot sondern wen sind Sie Rosa
ah das ist so typisch das ist so ein
typisches Männerding weißt du du ziehst
gelbe Strümpfe an dann sag ah orange ist
aber hässlich sagst nein gelb aber gut
ich nehme die rote böse Frage du nimmst
das ist rot bei uns keine
wiederw und die Grünen sind harmlos und
du kannst es selber wählen das nicht
toll ja und wahrscheinlich sind ist es
schwer eins auf dumm zu
machen ich verstehe die Frage
nicht das war die Antwort ach so ach
Gott nee du kannst schon ein bisschen
dazu was erzählen wie schwer soll es
sein auf dumm zu machen also sagen wir
es mal so es ist schwer auf dumm zu
machen
und nicht dabei zu erwischt zu werden
dass es nicht so ist oder das über eine
sehr lange Strecke auszuhalten aber wenn
sich dumm gut verkauft dann ist total
einfach weil ich für mich ist so das
typische Beispiel der der deutschen
Talkshow ist ein Schauspielerin die in
der ersten Minute irgendwann den Satz
sagt ich als
Künstlerin ja weißt du das ist das ist
nämlich so genau das ist nämlich genau
das Problem also ich muss nicht erkannt
werden oder wenn jetzt immer sag auch
die dumme Kraus ist völlig in Ordnung
was stört mich das und und und aber
Schauspieler sind ja meistens auch sehr
kapriziös du hast ja wahrscheinlich auch
gelegentlich mit denen zu tun die neähen
sich nämlich selbst als Künstler warah
ich bin dann doch so auf dem Tripp ich
bin dienstle ist darin und
hauptsache ich leiste meine Dienste und
dafür kriege ich mein Geld und ich muss
jetzt nicht
sozusagen mich verwirklichen in meinem
Job warum warum musst du das nicht jeder
eben Beruf Berufung hast du für diesen
Job keine Berufung ja weil ich das
genieße ich genieße das ich da sag jeden
Tag danke dass ich den Job machen darf
und wenn du mir sagst ich soll n
stüücken stüücken genau und wenn du
sagst ich soll blödsin machen oder ich
soll auf einem Bein bellend mir in der
Nase bohren dann mache ich das auch weil
es gibt definitiv schlimmere Jobs ja
aber warum du bist ja ich würde mal in
Antwort du bist hier für nichts zu blöd
zu schade nee also z.B bestes Beispiel
da geht auch ein Buch drum die
Journalisten als ich beim Glücksrad
angefangen habe als buchstabenfee sprich
buchstabenumdreherin so ziemlich der
blödeste Job im deutschen Fernsehen gab
natürlich weil man durfte eigentlich gar
nicht reden und dann und dann S und ich
hatte halt Mikro mir zumindest schon er
er erkämpft und fand das wahnsinnig
fortschrittlich und trotzdem hatte hatte
jeder so Rotze arrogant behandelt als
wärst du wirklich Gehirn amputiert und
ich hab mir so was läuft den hier falsch
Moment ich bin 23 Jahre alt verdiene mit
dieser stupiden langweiligen Arbeit
während wahnsinnig viel Kohle mehr als
Journalisten irgendwie
in J war sehr viel Geld d ich ich ich
ich ich ich genau ich will es gar nicht
sagen weil sonst kriege ich nie wieder
ein guten Artikel ja ich fand das
wahnsinnig intelligent für eine
23-jährige die damit Ihr komplettes Haus
umgebaut hat und sich irgendwie
finanziell dufte saniert hat ich fand
das sehr smart auf so dumm zu machen
aber geht das ein dann nicht auf die
Nerven wenn man denkt ich will aber mal
ernst genommen werden nein das mir doch
schnutz wenn mich da ernst nimmt weil
ich will doch gar nicht ernst genommen
werden ich finde es viel angenehmer dass
die Leute mich eben nicht ernst nehmen
und gelegentlich kommt das natürlich
zurück wie ein Boomerang weil wenn wir
jetzt jemand wieer wie ans ans Beinchen
pinkelt dann ist es natürlich auch so
dass ich auch
gelegentlich ich kann auch ich kann auch
beißen deswegen bin ich ja im bei den
bösen Jungs mit tv tv total immer als
die Maulhure unterwegs und als
schlappmaul aber das liegt jetzt auch
nicht in meiner Natur dass ich nur
schnappe ganz und gar nicht aber ich
kann es wenn man es bestellt okay gut
kommch war rot genau wir bestellen jetzt
mal was ja die roten sind
spannender ach wie auf dem Rummel toll
war deine Schwangerschaft eine
Torschlusspanik nein nein nein ich habe
gesagt ich habe irgendwann mal als
schlappmaul gesagt es war ein ganz
wunderbarer
Unfall war ein Unfall ja siehst du du
sagst jetzt nur Unfall meine Betonung
war wunderbarer Unfall ja
journalistisch
diese anstrengenden Menschen ja ähm und
äh hätte ich nicht wirklich schwanger
werden wollen wä ich es auch niemals
geworden aber ich wäre auch ohne Kind
glücklich geblieben
das ist super dass es passiert ist aber
Torschlusspanik ich glaube ich habe noch
bestimmt gute Zhen mestruierende Jahre
vor mir von daher könen wir noch was
erwarten ist noch ein bisschen Pause vor
der
Menopause ich kann noch ein bisschen du
kannst du kannst no mal eine grüne
ziehen ach wieso denn komm na gut okay
we ich bin ich bin ich bin schon gewohnt
dass alle immer so kommen mir immer so
Krawall gebürstet von daher es wird mich
echt jetzt langweilen wenn jetzt so eine
liebefrage kämen ja aber okay die sind
auch manchmal schwer zu beantworten echt
die lieben na komm dann dann dann
hättest du lieber etwas Richtiges
gelernt geil auch hättest du lieber
etwas Richtiges gelernt fragt da jemand
also ist ja so in grauer vorgeschicht
habe ich mal sowas gemacht das nennt
sich Abitur und danach habe ich fulltime
gemodelt weil ich mir dachte es wäre
eventuell schlau mir mit diesem
einfachen Job relativ viel Geld auf die
Kante zu legen damit ich da nicht
Kellnern
oder putzen muss um mir mein Studium zu
finanzieren und irgendwann habe ich dann
vielleicht auch nicht ganz so dumm
realisiert dass ich mit dem Modeln
ungefähr so viel verdiene wie ein
Arzt in Jahren berufserfahr nach 10
Jahren Berufserfahrung und dann dachte
ich es wäre eventuell auch nicht ganz so
dumm beim Modeln zu bleiben und ich habe
mir dann irgendwann gesagt wenn ich ein
Jahr weniger verdiene als das Jahr zuvor
dann schwenke ich um und fange an zu
studieren ist nie passiert und dann kam
es Fernsehen das hört sich jetzt alles
nach wahnsinnig Geld geiler Tussi an es
hört sich an rieseng Glück gehabt oder
war das für dich vorgezeichnet dass du
Model wirst gut bezahltes model ja das
das habe ich mir natürlich mit sehr viel
Disziplin und Zuverlässigkeit auch so
ein bisschen erarbeitet ja du wirst als
Model oder damals wurdest du als Model
nicht nur aufgrund deiner guten Visage
gebucht sondern auch ob du mal hilfst
den nicht so schade bist irgendwie beim
Regen dem Assistenten die Tüte
wegzutragen oder solche Sachen
teamfähigkeit ist da auch gefragt und
was für mich einfach als Frau immer so
verlockend war daran gutes Geld zu
verdienen ist weil Geld bedeutet für
mich nichts ich habe keine Fette Uhr an
ich habe jetzt keine Designerklamotten
an es ist für mich ganz wichtig aber
finanziell unabhängig zu sein weil
finanzielle Unabhängigkeit ist wieder
Selbstbestimmung hallo mal Ruhe da unten
Selbstbestimmung ähm
ja
Emanzipation okay und auch Schuhe
natürlich gelegentlich also nicht so
Tretter die ich jetzt anhab sondern fürs
Fernsehen ne wie hast frag nicht doch
wie viel Paar Schuhe hast du ich hab hab
irgendwann aufgehört zu zählen weil äh a
wir wollten ja mal lieben nehmen weil
das Berufsbekleidung meine meine hohen
Hacken mus ja das sind steh und
liegeschuhe privat trage ich sowas nicht
aber ich lieb sie trotzdem ja also von
daher so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt auf
eine liebe frrage was haben wir denn da
sie die die sind nämlich die sind
nämlich viel schwieriger schwiiger sind
ja bist du ein Design Naturtalent das
spielt wohl darauf an dass ich mal
Bikinis designed habe ja und
das fiel mir recht einfach weil ich
Bikinis sammel und ich habe jetzt ähm ja
ich habe früher sehr viel Bikini Mode
auch gemodelt von daher wusste ich
worauf es ankam da stieß ich aber dann
auch gelegentlich im design department
von hunkomöle an meine Grenzen weil wenn
ich dann mit irgendwelchen Feder Ruhe
Bendel ankam dann sagt die das ist nicht
umsetzbar in der maschinellen bzw
Massenproduktion und du wolltest begin
mit federbändeln genau also Bändchen mit
Federn und Muscheln irgendwo hängt und
so weiter und das hat da habe ich dann
auch noch gelernt und ansonsten ich
glaube von mir behaupten zu dürfen dass
ich ein sehr sehr gutes Auge habe für
gestalterische Dinge z.B meine Cover
meine Buchcover da gebe ich immer den
Ton ab dieses Cover pink ne ist jetzt
das erste Mal dass ich mich
äh von dem Verlag überzeugen hab lassen
dass wir das nehmen und nicht das was
ich gemacht habe und ich bereue es ein
bisschen ich geb zu man muss sich da
Bauch
Bauch so was soll ich jetzt noch mal
oder sind wir mchest noch eine so zum
Abschuss nehmen wir das wieder die rote
die rote ja ist viel oder wenn sie doof
ist dann nehmen wir andere doof sind
nicht
nein also hast du dein hast du dein
neues Buch wirklich selber geschrieben
ja ja ich habe mein neues Buch auch
selber geschrieben wie die davor auch
schon weil da ist
immer nicht immer da ist Stella drin
genau also die Stella das ist sozusagen
meine
stringente Gehirnzelle ja stella ist
eine Autorin die für mich alle Recherche
macht z.B eben auch zur fr Farbe pink da
sage ich ich habe irgendwann mal was
gelesen irgendwo in der und der Zeitung
und zum Thema sowieso oder Stella
recherchier mal
was jetzt Baustelle buy da war sie auch
schon mit am Start was ein Facelift
kostet was sind die Risiken da kenne ich
mich jetzt noch nicht so aus auch wenn
ich eigentlich mit einem als
37jährig mit einem Bein im Grab stehe
für euch ja aber das macht alles Stella
und Stella ist auch noch ganz großartig
weil sie einfach viel logischer denkt
als ich also ich bin so und ich schreib
mal da ich schreib mal da und Stella
bringt Struktur in meine Gedanken und
und sie hält mich auf Spur sie ist
sozusagen mein blinden Hund ja wenn ich
dann weil so ein Buch zu schreiben mit
400 Seiten und dann zum Ende zu kommen
ist auch schwierig und Stella macht halt
also wissenschaftliche Dinge und JA aber
das ist so persönlich meine Bücher jeder
der schon mal ein Buch von mir gelesen
hat weiß das kann kein anderer für mich
schreiben denn man kann es auch nicht
jetzt so erzählen und dass jemand
anderes aufschreibt das funktioniert
nicht und ich glaube da hört mich auch
jeder raus der da schon mal drin gelesen
hat kann ja nur ganz besonders geschickt
gemacht sein na ja dann müss schon
irgendwie jemand eine Freundin schreiben
aber Stella wohnt in Schweden und wir
kannten hallo Stella wie geht das dann
wie macht er das E-Mail E-Mail E-Mail ja
also sie gibt mir z.B auch Hausaufgaben
sagt du da ist noch ein bisschen dünn
schreib mir doch mal was zum Thema
ja ne und dann schreibe ich und ja super
und wir treffen uns dann natürlich auch
und und und bereden ganz viel oder
Baustelle Buddy da haben wir waren wir
eine Woche zusammen auf ibisa und wir
haben dann gebrainstormt alles zusammen
und
sie ist auch mein
müllablade Platz also das heißt ich
tippe auf mein Blackberry da tippe ich
wie eine bekloppte irgendwie was runter
und schickst dann schnell Stella und sie
sortiert dann ein das also sehr es
funktioniert gut und wie seid ihr
aufeinander gekommen ich meine Schweden
liegt ja nicht so nah ja wir haben uns
irgendwann mal über den Verlag her
kennengelernt ja und
und das war wirklich
Liebe auf den ersten Blick in der
Hinsicht weil wir uns einfach dufte
ergänzen aber ich glaube mit dir kann
man auch gut oder ich bin ein Teamplayer
ich habe ich ich ich es ist vielleicht
manchmal schwierig weil
dadurch dass ich gern ich habe kein
Problem mit irgendjemand and irgendwas
zu moderieren oder was mir echt fehlt in
dieser Branche ist oftmals
hört sich komisch an Geltungsdrang also
dir fehlt Geltungsdrang mir fehlt
Geltungsdrang en oder ja weil für mich
ist immer okay wenn es heiß auch das
machen wir dann in der Doppelmoderation
s ich fein gut cool währenddessen dann
Menschen nein jetzt mein Gott und da
jetzt eigentlich alleine das Moderieren
und zusammen ist auch fein aber du hast
ja offensichtlich genug um gut im
Geschäft zu sein weil es gibt ja viele
Kolleginnen und Kollegen die mit dir
angefangen haben da wissen wir heute die
Namen nicht mehr die einzige die mir
erhalten geblieben ist die Barbara
Barbara Schöneberger wir haben gemeinsam
angefangen und ja und dies blonden Gifte
haben sich durchgesetzt ja und oh siehst
du die Grünen sind viel schwieriger was
ist das Geheimnis deiner Schönheit danke
Schätzchen das Geheimnis meiner
Schönheit ist komplett entschlüsselt und
zwar brutal in einem Buch das nen sich
Baustelle Bud wurde von mir auch
verfasst war auch ein Bestseller und da
ist kein Geheimnis das ist einfach
Tuning knohow und von Natur schön bin
ich weit entfernt noch noch eine
und dann machen wir Schuss das ist ja
auch schon Bestseller B ganz STZ bra nur
ja drei Bestseller ist schon mal weiß
dem ersten Buch als als nach dem ersten
Buch war es wirklich so wenn jemand
gesagt hat Autorin dann Dach oh Gott sag
doch sowas nicht Hilfe ja ich hatte so
viel Respekt vor diesem Autorin und so
langsam nach drei Büchern denkst du
so verdammt ja ich bin Autorin ihr könnt
mich alle mal ich bin
Künstlerin das ist sieh woher hast du
dein Selbstbewusstsein die Grünen sind
viel schwieriger zu beantworten aber zum
Thema Selbstbewusstsein das ist halt
eine lange Geschichte die auch in dem
Schinken da steht
ach jetzt aber mal gut was machen die
denn das hört sich an als würde Godzilla
furzen da unten oder unglaublich wer
weiß vielleicht kommen wir nicht mehr
Leben raus
auch ich war nicht immer selbstbewusst
also ich war eigentlich mal ein ganz
schüchternes Mädchen und dann ist etwas
passiert in meinem Leben und darauf habe
ich reagiert und
äh zwar so dass ich gemerkt habe dass es
einfacher ist auf Menschen offen
zuzugehen ich bin nicht frei von
Selbstzweifeln in keinster Weise aber es
ist nun mal so dass ich gemerkt habe es
ist vielleicht eine Offenheit ich bin
unerschrocken offen und jeder kriegt von
mir Bonus also vorschusskredit und äh
ähm mittlerweile weiß ich auch von mir
selbst aus Erfahrung dass ich stark
genug bin wenn mir dann jemand doof
kommt oder blöd zu mir ist oder versucht
mich zu verletzen dass ich das händeln
kann aber das sind halt so Sachen die
muss man erstmal ausprobieren man muss
halt irgendwie so den Anstoß haben also
auszuprobieren offen auf Leute zuzugehen
und sie auch einzuladen und oftmals
merkt man dann aber auch wenn man die
Leute einlädt ähm und sehr nah an sich
ranlässt und äh
ähm ja äh viel von sich auch Preis gibt
was andere missbrauchen könnten dass sie
dann gar nicht mehr die Veranlassung
sehen das zu tun mhm und
äh ja und
eine Strategie auch zu einem
unerschütterlichen selbstbewusin ist
auch sehr viel eine große Prise Wahrheit
weil ähm Lügen machen angreifbar und
Wahrheit ist irgendwie entwaffnend und
wenn ich bei der Wahrheit bleibe wer
kann mir denn da schon was du hast es
gerade noch mal den den Selbstmord
deines Vaters
angesprochen wenn man sowas Negatives
erlebt ist es dann auch ist das so ein
Ausgangspunkt wo man sich sagt hey alles
was jetzt kommt ja kann ja eigentlich
nur besser sein natürlich und du weißt
ich habe das überlebt dann werde ich
auch alles weitere überleben und
das macht dich natürlich selbstbewusst
und das vielleicht gerade diese diese
Kindheitserfahrung hab mich natürlich
auch dann gewappnet
ähm für diese Branche weil wenn ihr mir
jemand irgendwie was Böses will und mich
versucht mit irgend welchen Kritiken
oder moralischen Predigten zu verletzen
oder mit irgendetwas dann ist es
natürlich dass ich denke
so netter Versuch aber ich weiß was
wirklich weh tut im Leben und was
schlimm ist im Leben und von
daher ist das jetzt für mich so tragisch
wie
das berüchtigte berüt berüchtigte gleich
gleichsgewicht pro Problem eines
asiatischen Grundnahrungsmittel im
Beutel verpackt in Südostchina ja also
der sackreist der sackreist bisschen
aber und noch eine Nachfrage dazu und
ist das auch so ein auspankpunkt wo man
sagt ist ich pfeife jetzt aus auf die
anderen ich mache das was mir Spaß macht
und ich verhalte mich so wie es mir
gefällt und nicht wie es anderen
gefällt so ignorant bin ich dann auch
nicht weil also nicht störend auf die
anderen aber nicht störend das stören
einfach nur dass ich mir nicht anderen
erzählen was ich eben ich trage muss ich
Trauer tragen Z ja ja das schon das
schon aber ich habe schon den Anspruch
dass ich den meinen Mitmenschen gut bin
und dass ich dass ich auch irgendwie äh
ähm äh dass ich dass ich dass ich den
also ich bin ich bin eine sanfte Seele
und ich bin jetzt bei Talk Talk Talk
wenn da jemand sagt dass er sozusagen
die Tochter die zöfjährige Tochter
seiner Freundin knallt dann finde ich
hat er das verdient dass man Scheiße
übern spricht ja oder wenn jemand so
viel Blödsinn labert und so so so so
grottoides Zeug daher stammelt dann hat
das verdient dass man ja der sich über
ihn zumindest lustig macht m aber ich
versuche mit meiner Umgebung immer sehr
sehr zärtlich umzugehen und sehr
behutsam und
sehr ja ich liebe auch Menschen ehrlich
gesagt und
wenn man die Erfahrung hat gezeigt das
zahlt sich aus und das ist eine gute
Strategie fürs Leben
hört sich so an Gott werden wir hier
noch richtig tief nee hör auf bloß nicht
ja doch aber es ist es ist halt nmer so
dass dass viele Menschen sich verleiten
lassen von Äußerlichkeiten und das ist
sehr lustig denn in meiner modelzeit
habe ich gelernt da sehr zu
differenzieren und auch durch Optik
hindurch zu sehen ich lasse mich von
Schönheit nicht mehr Blenden das ist
sehr gesund gewesen
diese Zeit mit sehr vielen attraktiven
Menschen für mich und
äh
dadurch
ähm sehe ich Menschen oftmals besser als
andere das sehen die äh besser sehen
können als hören ich nicht ich kann
besser hören als sehen vielen Dank Gerke
schön